Time ticks forward any English,
but did you know in Mandarin earlier is
up and later is down or that the UK Tech
Maya have no word for before or after
these sound like the kind of fun facts you
share with a friend and then move on.
But for linguists,
time is at the center of a major debate.
Are there languages out there were time
just doesn't work like we think it does.
There's a linguist who spent his
entire career documenting and trying to
understand one language,
Hopi after four years of field
work in Arizona on the third Mesa,
surely he has real insights to share
about every aspect of the language.
And yet in this lung book he
focuses on just one Hopi time,
over 600 pages of Hopi time.
With example after example of how just
like English hope he has words for time,
like later temporarily,
the Hopi count days,
they use terms like over there as spatial
metaphors for time and their verbs
have tenses. They can mark
the future with ne time, time,
everywhere time. Okay, so
the hope he can tell time,
what's the big deal?
Well,
it must've mattered to someone because
linguists and psychologists and people
who never heard a word of hope in their
lives grabbed the book and held it high
as proof that time was universal for
humans and then they cursed the name of
warf. Warf was wrong.
Warf was a charlatan.
Warf was a con man. Oh
fuck. What's the fuss?
Whoever said that, the hope you
don't think about the past, present,
and future plus who's this wharf and
YC getting picked on so much worth.
What's a fire inspector,
but one with a unique hobby
Youdo as tech in languages.
This curiosity led him to Sapir
who took wharf under his wing.
Just, Hey, I've got some literature
that will blow your mind.
See Hambelton Boaz taught us how different
cultures subconsciously categorize
the world based on language,
but I think there's more.
I think people are at
the mercy of language.
We're not living in the objective world,
man. We're living through our language.
What an hod idea,
but as worth turn to another
Uto-Aztecan language.
She started to see it.
Hopi seemed so on European to
him in the way it handled time.
There was no substance called time
and no timeline that could be cut and
counted.
No space as a metaphor for time
as if you could move through time,
not even a past, a
present, or a future tense.
The more worth studied Hopi,
the more he concluded that the Arrow of
time isn't something that exists in our
objective world.
Instead,
we think about time this way
because we speak average European.
The Hopi don't share our concept
of time because they speak Hopi.
How do the Hopi live without
tense? Well, for warf,
Hopi time is about cycles.
Rituals,
mental preparation for key events.
Above all,
they have no objective time.
Sapir died at age 55 and warf
joined him a couple years later,
age to 44 but his ideas were captivating.
Do people think about time
differently in different languages?
Does your language shape
your concept of time?
Does the language you speak to determine
whether or not time even exists for you?
These claims from weak to strong
got the Nickname Sapir wharf,
which I often hear pronounced saper wharf.
Hopi time became it's posterchild
and an ever growing big fish tail.
Hope he is innocent of a
category for time and no worse.
Our concept of time would
be in comprehensible to them
better yet the reason you
have clocks and watches is because you
aren't Hopi and my favorite hobby time
makes for better family therapy then
the Aristotelian reality western parents
are stuck in.
So now do you see the power of the
600 pages spent vanquishing wharf and
mainstreaming?
Hopi linguists had had enough.
Many of them wanted to focus on what
made language universal and in nature to
all of us stop parading around
Hopi as an exotic oddity.
We all think the same way.
We just express ourselves with
a little linguistic flair.
So then time is time is time.
It's settled,
not quite. dot.dot. Years after Hopi time,
researchers claim that they'd found new
evidence showing wharf was right about
time.
All along like this set of experiments
playing on the difference between how
English and Mandarin speakers you space
to talk about time earlier is to your
left and later to your right in English.
But in Mandarin, things can get vertical.
Earlier is up and later down.
Even though these experiments were
conducted entirely in English,
native Mandarin speakers were quicker
to answer simple questions about earlier
or later after being primed
with vertical tos. Well,
native English speakers were
faster after horizontal cues.
Thinking about time,
it seemed was shaped by language.
The masses were intrigued,
myself included,
someone passed me a link to it
and my work inbox years ago,
and I wasn't even working with linguists,
but in the comments of
my old video about warf,
a researcher did mention having trouble
replicating these results from what I've
read since then,
that commentary isn't alone still.
It was just one of the many wharf like
effects that kept making the news some
from scientific tests in the lab,
others from fieldwork on the ground.
So in the central Andes, there's a
language spoken by millions called Imada.
In Aymara, you're Neda, your eye
is in front of you and your keeper,
you're back is behind you.
That's normal.
But this isn't when talking about time,
the eye motto speak as
if they face the past,
but they have their backs to the future.
They even point behind their
backs to gesture into the future.
So their eyes are exactly
where your eyes are,
but their past is not
where your past is rare,
unique,
but there's something else about I
Mana and hoping at second glance,
some linguists tell us both of
them are best viewed as tenseness.
Wait, there are timeless
languages out there. What?
Well kind of tense lists.
It's not as odd as it first sounds.
We already know of languages that
are uncontroversially tenseness take.
You could tech Maya.
Not only are they missing a past,
present and future tense.
They even lack words like
before until and after.
How in the world do they talk
about time? Well, strategies,
complex strategies like context aspect.
It could make a fun followup to dig
into the mechanics of how Tencent's
languages talk about time,
but good luck proving any of this makes
them experience time in a fundamentally
different way.
You could,
tech speakers do fine and experiments
about linear time and any effects are
subtle. See if you read the research
and not the breaking headlines,
strong ideas of language,
determining time. Those are out.
Any ongoing debates are about
subtler influences in the end.
Languages do talk about time differently,
but it's harder to get speakers to behave
differently based on their language.
But I'll level with you.
I get the sense of trivia about
time and tenses was never the point.
Hopi time became a mascot for a
grander idea. Linguistic relativity,
whereas Sapir put it, different
societies live in distinct worlds,
not merely the same world with
different labels attached.
That's an idea I suspect we'll run
into again in the future until then.
Stick around it.
Subscribed for language.